[Music]
today I will be showing your game played
by grandmaster Nakamura this year
against a very strong top-five player
Sergei Kuryakin from Russia and I want
you to see these ideas some of the ideas
will be advanced and some interesting
ideas and I'll explain why Nakamura was
playing this it was an excellent
positional game by him and he won this
game so white Nakamura black is Kuryakin
Russian Grandmaster c4 g6 at this point
we don't know yet which opening is going
to be there are few different options so
he plays Knight c3 and he played the
move d5 so immediately we have which
opening bloomfeld defense ok Grune felt
immediately we have a very very popular
opening here
d5 takes Knight takes d5 and now don't
rush efore is the one of the main moves
but that's not what nakamura played
groom felt is a very theoretical line
opening and there are so many different
things lines happening and usually it's
very difficult to prove much advantage
there in the main line so Nakamura
played Bishop d2 move very interesting
move the idea is after he plays efore
and black takes on c3 he wants to take
back with the bishop on c3 that's what
he wants to do ok so he wants to play E
for and if he takes Bishop takes c3 yeah
that's one of the main lines and that's
what happened here another move here is
Knight b6 but then white plays III
protecting before so that's another idea
so Bishop d2 he played Bishop g7
developing his Bishop and now logical
move evil Knight goes back
v6 is one of the ideas but then white
will go Bishop III even though he wasted
time it's okay because now who is
controlling the center white see that's
why he has the control of all the
squares in the center so that's why he
didn't want to try that line he played
the move Knight takes c3 Bishop takes c3
the supership is very well placed here
now protecting the center and it's on a
good position and now he plays c5 black
is too trying to attack the center
immediately
now if you are playing this position now
after c5 what do you do well think think
about it because if you allow him to
take and exchange your center you're not
gonna have much advantage so this one is
extremely important if you're still
trying to get an advantage you almost
have to play this without hesitation
otherwise you're not gonna get advantage
we should be 5 check is possible yes but
yeah Bishop e5 check is possible but the
problem is he can just go Bishop d7 yeah
the problem is he will just go to d7
okay
if he go Bishop b5 then he just goes
Bishop to d7 so the move you have to
play is defiled absolutely correct you
have to have a pawn on d5 if you're
fighting for advantage okay
you have to okay otherwise he's just
gonna exchange it and you're not gonna
have advantage here 933 it's a normal
move it's a norm of developing move
unfortunately he takes and then we don't
have a center okay then he's exchange so
you have to play d5 now Bishop takes c3
check pawn takes c3
and now he castles I might need to reset
this
okay
let me just just a second I'll just get
a new board so we don't have this it was
an allowing block to castle so
Castle okay so he castled now Knight f3
played by nakamura and immediately
Kuryakin knows in stop grandma said that
he needs to attack the center
immediately because white will have a
very strong position if he doesn't
attack the center so he plays the move
he's 6 now white plays Bishop e2
developing development is very important
here for y so takes takes c4 when
instead of development risky risky
he takes then he can go check and also
you open up this diagonal maybe I
couldn't come check here - okay so it's
risky so you go Bishop e2 he takes you
take takes takes it goes Bishop to g4
now developing the bishop white he is
trying to just activate the bishop and
now what to do here Castle and he plays
Knight to d7 now he plays Knight to d7
and now let's see let's think about it
here
we're doing is the best move here for
white what he can try to do here
well rocky one is one idea you have what
else
brookey one is going to go to create for
example keep the bishop which bishop e I
kick the bishop h3 so you want to force
him to take it okay that's what he did
he kicked the bishop yes he is
questioning it and also but besides
kicking it what else useful he is doing
there is something useful he is
accomplishing now by kicking the bishop
loft he is creating us looked it's good
well you can call the flight square
escape square or loft loft is the
official way it's a word air I think in
German can lift looked yeah yeah so it's
good yeah it's for air so he's got the
escape square now he created a lift for
the king for the king yes to avoid the
background checkmates to avoid the
background checkmate okay so remember
that that is the loft okay and he's he
won't start loft for the King but also
he wants to question the bishop and see
what is he gonna do now this is very bad
obviously g4 retreating is also not so
good normally I'll tell you this if you
have this structure they kick you with
h3 you've got to take it because going
back it's bad you can get trapped okay
h3 now Bishop f3 plate Bishop takes f3
and now he played Knight e5 activating
the night and attacking your bishop
so now what you should do here what do
you think he should keep the bishop or
he should allow him to exchange bishop
is important to keep okay and he is
keeping the bishop he is keeping the
bishop bishop like this it's already
usually good versus the night like this
because the night only five is
restricted the bishop only two is
cutting the night off okay
it's cut okay cannot do yes
play what
well you gotta watch out these six a six
now okay T six
so a four
maybe come in here yeah but this is
before
some queen defy even queen d5 Livan
Livan this is very risky for you what if
I go here actually you know what okay
yeah well if I put this rook here it
will be over because then you know he
can't protect anything yeah but Julian
this is you understand when the pawn is
on a seventh you understand right it's
okay well it's interesting but yeah
that's not what Kuryakin wants to do he
wants to blockade okay blockade not
allowed the pawn to get there on the
seventh when opponent has passed pawn
what do you do first thing blockade him
well if you can capture him of course
you do that but assuming you cannot
capture you blockaded see here if he can
manage to put the knight on the six
block is absolutely absolutely fine but
there's no way for him to get there on
time you know here yes okay attack push
it push it
yeah but rook p1 Bishop is too strong
here for the night too strong so it was
95 Bishop e2 plate and Kuryakin plays
the move 26 and he must have been happy
here because more or less it looks like
black should be fine here
what did Nakamura play here a very
strong move well if you play upon a 4
he's gonna go back on b7 anyway he wants
to go back so you're kind of creating
some more weaknesses I'm not sure if we
should do that ok I'm not entirely sure
if we need to do that
you can go queen bee tree that's an idea
what else
rook p1 when you have a rook hiding
behind your pawn and there is an
opportunity what do you do bring him in
right rook belongs where open files
that's it
rook be one of course attacking the pawn
now he plays b6 protecting that b7 pawn
and now another neat move here next
couple of moves I really like with
Nakamura played here what is the next
move here you could play a four what
else let's think about it let's think
about it so we find the best move
first you always have to look at your
development yeah so you can see which
pieces develop which pieces are not
developed because development is the key
to the success the key to success is
development and the movies absolutely
correct look to e1 exactly
nice move now
Kuryakin goes Luke FD 8 attacking on d5
dink-dink c4 would be a positional
mistake here
Bishop a6 exactly
look at that move the point is after he
plays Bishop a6 if you take he wants to
exchange and look at that winning the
rogue even better than that is actually
c4 because c4 is winning a full-piece a
full-piece okay not in exchange a full
piece okay everybody got this all right
now he goes here rook b8 stopping that
idea and now what do we do now we play
c4 and you see the difference now if you
play c4 you block your own Bishop you
lose your advantage she was still better
but a little bit but see he plays very
very nice looking fish base 6 and then
only c4 Bishop is very active and blood
can never push his pants they're blocked
now c4 Knight d7 this Knight is not very
stable here so it tries to bring the
knight to f6 Bishop b5 and now it was
here Knight f6
and now it's very very important for why
to control the whole efile here okay
Queen eight for route p7 not much will
be accomplished there you'll just
protect it so so what about the idea of
Queenie to controlling the e-file right
he can never go to the e-file now and in
some point here Queenie sock weeny five
any seven ideas yes
oh you can do that look look what he did
he did very nicely actually he did the
same I day one here Queenie to rook p7
you just need to find the cameras move
here if you find it then you're gonna
see it he is doing that exactly now what
did he do here he wants to control the
e-file completely rook b3 exactly look
at that idea nicely nicely done rugby
three
now he goes Knight h5 see the problem
for black is his worse but it's the most
important thing is no country play for
him
y can just gradually improve the
position the white is just black he's
just sitting there with no contra play
he cannot do anything on this side and
he cannot do anything on the centre so
black white is better everywhere now he
goes here
rook III and now 97 very important
moment in a game here 97 and the
question is what do you do first of all
you need to recognize his threat
what is it threatening aha
he wants to play Knight here right
Knight a5 and d4 so what are we going to
do to stop that
g4 look at that can go here Knight has
no squares to go to now did you realize
that g4 is just completely shutting down
that night no squares to go to that
night is trapped now he goes King f8 and
I played a four here advancing the part
in some point also a5 will be something
that black needs to worry about and now
he cannot do anything yes
rook e8 and if I were rook e8 yeah but I
don't have to take out I go rookie seven
and neutralized everything look at this
why would you want to trade this Hawks
with this rope
only if you're winning only if you have
a forced made you do that okay
only in that circumstances otherwise you
don't want to exchange if you exchange
one or two pieces then it's gonna be
equal so okay a four-block doesn't have
anything no plan so he's like okay let
me just play a five here create
something for the rook here to go to but
f 5 is also weakening the position the
weekend is six now we can is six any
five squares now he plays rook e5 takes
and how you gonna take back of course to
cover the squares and now he plays rook
f7 let's see if you can find
Nakamura's plan here
how you can try to improve one of whites
pieces here rookie six-night xe6
okay well let's see
rookie six we understand takes takes
rookie seven yeah we'll discuss that one
second check and what is this what do
you get
Brooke f8 is next if you don't win right
away then you lose because you down
exchange you might lose okay so that
doesn't work
Bishop p8 interesting idea but again we
don't want to exchange because he takes
we take he takes see lots of
liquidations and this is gonna favor
black because black is squeezed no space
no squares to go to so liquidations help
we'll help him only okay we don't want
to exchange here because look at this
he's just running out of squares for his
pieces so what do you do huh dink-dink
of a plan first which piece you can try
to improve to create a mating thread
Queen III okay it's more proper this way
look at that control this and the idea
is Queen to h6 you see that and after
the queen is on h6 what do you do rook
e8 checkmate okay you will check made
him so Kuryakin sees the threat and he
doesn't want to get mated like that
without contra play so he was Queen f6
now stopping Queen h6 or now how
you see that how are you gonna defend
against that threat so you can continue
with the same idea push the pawn Queen
takes pawn which move excellent
rookie - and Nakamura is renewing the
same threat Queen age six now and then
rook e8 idea see he wants to get this
just an idea to show you check check
mate check checkmate
got it
now queena 4 is offering exchange of the
queens
Oh we take we take we take he takes now
this rook is getting active so what do
we do when opponent has active piece we
trade and let's take a look at this
position it's very very important here
that he cannot play 98 ok because if you
can play 98 96 black doesn't have any
problems but if he plays 98 what do you
do you have to play this move here
exactly
rook takes actually because you want to
go to the king opponent game King and
pawn endgame is easily won here because
you have a protected passed pawn and you
can create a second pass pawn you don't
have to play g5 like here you push f4
you go f5 takes takes he cannot attack
this one because you push this one ok he
cannot attack both pawns okay here if he
goes back he push because you Queen you
cannot do both okay
you cannot do both so that's why you
create a passed pawn with that 5 so it's
very important a 98 is losing okay for
this position now he played h5 trying to
get rid of that panel on g4 so finally
he can get his night in but Nakamura is
not letting him do that right f3 she
wants to keep that night restricted for
the rest of the game King f7 now which
piece you want to improve King of course
King comes in on g2 King f6
now he played you know just just a
normal move rookie one he wants to have
the rook here just in case this age pawn
is gonna be advanced or anything okay so
you just got to route back to e1 and now
g5 and now kink to g3 knocking to g3
rook h8 and now what's the plan here huh
what will be the winning plan here for
white
well d6 is coming up but the problem
with this is you allow this idea okay
Bishop c6 first c6 he has bishop c6
first he wants to go bishop c6 king f7
push now he wants to push he goes check
because here walking up on the problem
is he cannot even go night here because
a bishop d5 so he goes king f6 posh now
he goes 96 trying to get the night end
he attacks
now night the 98 there is a rook da tidy
rook e8 idea so it tastes 97 attacking
the bishop and now very strong move here
very strong move here played by nakamura
tink don't rush think you need to find a
winning idea now because you have a
polymer 7th strong Bishop and your rook
is very active to you what is the plan
of this should be 7 well it's and we
know it's tough but you have to find a
breakthrough
he found a breakthrough right here and
that's what you need to do here try to
find it the bishop was just there
Mitchell it was like this so he goes
here we go attack takes
takes king of six yeah well he gave up
all the palms already so it's very
Jewish don't rush no actually he's got
the right pawn but he missed one of the
key moves the right one is f4 takes g5
but when he takes what is the idea
better one move and it's over here one
move finished even King f6 takes King g7
tough one this is a nice smooth but
Tuffy you just gave up two pounds you
just gave up two pounds they can play
kimchi tree if you don't win here then
why did we give up to two pounds correct
excellent job
bishop g8 very nice look at that
that's a beautiful move now he's gonna
Queen nineteen not to stop it very
strong it's a move that you can miss but
that's why I'm showing you this game
mainly I really like this Bishop g8 idea
and if he takes do you see why he kept
the King here not here he had this idea
in his mind like ten months ago he had
this idea so you can go check and pick
it up all right
so Kuryakin cannot take now so it goes
here even though he's up upon but it's
it's completely lost here so couple of
moves he played King g6 rook c5
protecting the pawn because next he
wants to bring the bishop check King
f7 Bishop f5
rook h8 kingi to a5 King F to bring the
King here and now he has no moves
because if he plays actually just take
you cannot take this D Punk wins so he
played f3 and I can what I didn't even
take this he could have he went just
here there is no hurry because what is
the next move here for black let's say
he tries to move this here what is the
finishing touch here don't rush when you
say good move
look for a better one
takes all right excellent so he cannot
do anything so he resigned here because
he has no moves why to pick up this
Paula left three then he will go to G
for pick up the other pawn and promote
let's just see why he resigned here for
example if he goes here right so you can
take this one you can go here now I take
the second one he cannot even take this
you're gonna Quinn no check push nothing
moves then you can even bring the King
here and just complete domination the
reason I like this game and I think to
show you today because not often you see
when two top five top 10 players play
one player can really dominate one
position early like this you know
starting from the opening all the way
until the moment where he resigned move
52 all right now at the end we're gonna
do a study okay okay difficult but okay
you need to also the studies white to
play and draw we have extra piece but we
are not in a position to try to even
think about winning this so we can only
try to hold and make a draw here how can
we do that
we should too
kingi forth kingi for ya King takes age
five yeah here we have them yeah
be sure to see shaking a four and then
the problem is he wants to Queen that's
the problem and if the Queen C is going
to win the game so what do we do
we should pay for d1 Quinn Bishop a
folder is d1 Quinn well think about it
that idea is actually a fork so we have
the right start actually there should be
eight King h5 only move because if I
queen then skew right so we have the
start here we need to figure out the
concept here how we can draw this
position because we're not going to be
able to stop him from winning yes 94 if
d1 and if you check
he takes if you check he takes and he
has this escape square unfortunately he
has that square but we can do something
we can fix that we can fix that idea and
come up with a we you know not winning
but drawing concept here
excellent
perfect excellent job you see that one
he got the same idea but now he
sacrificed a bishop just a little bit
different square just a little bit and
now we see the concept here of the study
all right so let's do this again
so Bishop e8 by the way if it was 93
it's easy draw bishop check takes 94 and
93 okay take take so that's why he has
to go King g4 now Bishop h5 doesn't work
idea right away so we go check he moves
away Bishop g4 check now sorry tricks
stopping the threat and now 94 he has to
do something so if you're playing
somebody and you reach this position
what would be the best thing to do here
for black because if you promote into a
queen it's gonna be draw immediately
what is the best move here to keep the
game going it's still probably a draw
but keep the game going no that's dead
wrong right they draw 93
what do you promote apart to keep the
game going in here they're sure you put
the bishop because at least you can keep
on going there you know it's not
immediate raw anything else you do it's
immediate drop immediate draw so Queen
check takes still wait all right
excellent good job everyone and I'll see
you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]